As a swordsman, I underestimated this
nao 4 days early nao It
's not suitable for their players
If you just thought that you were safe
Uh-huh
[music] As a
new species, I
'm strong without it, I can't.
I can't believe my
strength I
have many friends I couldn't protect until now
Isn't it a wound that could have been avoided if it was strong?
Enemy heroes really don't exist in this world,
right?
I
'm the same as you, my friend and I are the same.
I don't know how to do it,
but I'm
strong You're strong
If you're on my right, I feel like even an imperfect me can
stand in front of everyone with the face of a champion,
tan What the hell,
I
'm not perfect.
I need you, I'm going to
change